what's happening reject nation hahaha
John here I'm here
Renee Arielle from Instagram and Twitter
that's where she's from race follow her
there she is part of clever TV and
clever news afterbuzz TV as well she's
she's just becoming this ultimate host
of all internet things and also she has
her dating blog sexting in this city hey
Renee transition time have you ever had
to meet a boyfriend's father yes well
that's not what this movie is about but
that's the best I got for this
transition great segue daddies know part
two that's what we pride ourselves on
most as segways yeah human what I know
from this group at this couch I'm the
only one that seemed daddy's home part 1
so there's a sequel Renee's favorite
celebrity Mel Gibson's in here and
John's favorite celebrity John Cena's in
here
I do like and John Lithgow what gout I
love him I said Renee Arielle again
didn't I you might have Renee irony Aria
I'm sorry what I should be called great
both of your names even more wrong day
one yeah
[Music]
together Christmas like family Christmas
grandpa dusty Lee who wouldn't be
impressed with you
to bring the car out the driver took the
same trailer so this code - thank you
gotta ask another man's permission to
see wrong tells you about all of her
problems with the guys she's actually
beating it's called the friendzone the
worst advice anyone can give you you all
be like dragging me in the friend zone
you wanna be like dad into the end zone
[Music]
perfect together you don't think I can
operate a chainsaw
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I could tell by your guys's reaction
that you two are definitely gonna be
paying $13 at your local Cinemark North
Hollywood Plex to go watch this movie
I'm gonna double feature this and bad
moms because I'm equally as excited yeah
what would you rather watch daddy's home
to or bad mom's Christmas I'm sorry
spiritually I want to say bad moms too
but I feel like just I don't know the
jokes in this trailer appealed to me
more the feminists and me and the one
who wants to look good in front of all
women the ten women who watched this
channel I wish more well I want to say
bad mom's Christmas daddy zone - I'm
just way more drunk - yeah I'm one of
this this is not gonna make me look good
I know Renee I've been a supporter of
Mel Gibson's comeback for quite some
time now yes I know you were first
celebrity news go into it this is gonna
make me look good but you know I like
Will Ferrell the problem with this movie
that I see happening it's kind of how I
felt about the first daddy so I feel
like when they focus in on like dialogue
and committing to absurdity and dialogue
that's when it's funny but when they go
like full slapstick like cutting down
the tree and stuff like that yeah it
just looks like corny dumb
comedy to me and I don't know you got
it's it's like it's so weird watching
The Bad Moms Christmas trailer seeing a
bunch of strong powerful actresses in
one movie and it's stupid kind of comedy
and then the same kind of thing here
very similar concept it's almost the
same thing just like hey sell that right
yeah call Jeff Hollywood hey well he
messed up I should just help him out you
know I'm not excited for this at all I
don't think they needed a second one I'm
I don't like it well I don't think
Nate's like one and it's just overload
like the humor is just overload for me I
just don't find it funny I think all
this all the humors and all the jokes in
this movie I just like has been over
done the telephone pole really my and
then they put that in the trailer
because I'd like they really want people
to watch it yeah I'm hoping that having
John Lithgow and Mel Gibson I hope that
when the for them are on-screen together
Will Ferrell Mark Wahlberg Mel Gibson
John Lithgow when they're all on screen
and John Cena John Cena like when
they're all there I'm hoping that's
really funny the first trailer I thought
was funnier this one was like alright
I'm probably still gonna see it just
because I surprisingly like the first
one like half of it I'll probably tune
in again for this one but yeah you know
I mean I feel like this is the kind
these are both the kinds of movies where
if you're into that kind of movie then
you'll probably really dig it but this
just is it is the audience just daddy's
home daddy's watch eco type of Christmas
movies all right yeah they're all
Christmas themed yeah I'm just kind of
over I was just done Alf and then left
it at that yeah dude elf is great that's
the only Christmas movie that he should
this I mean maybe there'll be another I
would I would rather watch an elf two
than this and I don't think that they
should make it you know what they would
call elf to elf up
oh no yeah no
yes it's a raunchy elf movie that
actually that that's seriously buck up
see I should work for you mr. Hollywood
hey guys subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification Bell Det John
Humphrey hi dat like dad whatever it's
on working dad John Humphrey on Twitter
and Instagram
Rene Ariel on Instagram and Twitter
follow her her social media is blowing
up probably because you can also catch
her on clever TV and clever news Leyva
and wait a minute she's also on what's
the after afterbuzz TV and also she has
her sexting in the city blog where she
gives you ultimate dating advice but
it's also funny I do yeah
that's what I do that's how you promote
someone watch it go it RNA we're just
can't we fight yeah at Rene REO